مبتهجون لاعبوا المنتخب الاسترالي يصلون
الى قطر
يكتشف بكل حماس معسكره الذي سيقيم فيه
طيله ايام المنافسه
رائعه كل ما علينا هو اللعب
يستنكر فيه العديد من اللاعبين مقتل
الالاف العمال في مواقع البناء لكن بمجرد
الوصول الى الدوحه لن يسمح بالتطرق الى
هذا الموضوع نفس الحالي مع الدنمارك بعد
رفض الفيفا السماحه للاعبين بارتداء قمصان
دونت عليها عباره حقوق الانسان للجميع
يجب ان يكون اللاعبون القادرين على
التركيز على كاس العالم
التي تحمل الوان قوس قزح الداعمه للمثليين
افخاص عندما نرحب بالاجانب في فرنسا
ويحترم ثقافتنا سافعل الشيء نفسه عندما
اذهب الى قطر
بتصعد لهجتها تدريجيا مع اقتراب المونديال
تتواصل وتتسع وتتضمن افتراءات وازدواجيه
معايير
الدبلوماسيه ايضا عندما انتقدت وزيره
الداخليه الالمانيه في اكتوبر الماضي من
حق قطر كاس العالم سارعت الدوله الخليجيه
لاستدعاء السفير الالماني وتسليمه مذكره
احتجاج رسمي